validation it feels great to feel seen
supported and appreciated and you know
set in the right context it's also
something that can make us feel like we
have found our people in our home
it can also be something that is used in
place of compensation in places
especially in the flow arts and today I
want to talk a little bit about that and
why it might be a negative thing Drex
here from drexfactor pull is sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flowers to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to talk about something
that is part of flow Arts culture that I
think we should maybe put under a bit of
a lens but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flowfests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
oh my goodness so it has been bitterly
cold in D.C for most of the past week
with really high winds and wind chills
that are well below freezing this is the
first warm day we've had in some time so
hope you don't mind if I do a little bit
of walking as I talk with you about this
topic so I've had the idea for this
video rolling around in my head now for
months and with a lot of flow festivals
now releasing their teaching lineups I
thought it might be a good opportunity
to dive into this topic because I
actually think that it's kind of an
important one so I'm going to start this
off by telling a story I remember many
many years ago being at a flow Festival
that I will not name and watching their
Gala performance and leaving it just
kind of feeling not just uninspired but
kind of angry like it was one of those
things that in sitting through all of
these performances I overwhelmingly got
the feeling that the people performing
in the gala were not there to inspire me
or show me interesting new things but
that it was my job as an audience member
to make them feel good about the fact
that they got up on stage and I found
much to my great disappointment that
that experience wasn't terribly unique
either that year or at that or other
festivals and not just that it was being
reflected in several other aspects of
the festivals too one of the other ways
I saw this manifesting was in the
teaching line of said a lot of festivals
you know I remember going to my first
fire Festival back in what was it 2009
and being absolutely Blown Away by the
wide variety of international talent
that they'd brought out for the event to
teach
and a lot of lineups I've seen lately
just aren't nearly as inspiring and not
just that it became clear as time went
on that the vast majority of people that
were making up these teaching lineups
weren't getting paid to do so
sometimes they were getting a cop ticket
to come in but other than that they were
essentially paying to teach at these
events I myself would frequently find
that I would lose money going to events
to teach and I was actually getting
travel stipends I can't imagine how much
money people were losing who weren't
getting travel stipends at all
and I began to wonder
how did it make sense for people to do
this after pondering this for months I
came to an inescapable conclusion
that the compensation that people were
looking for to teach at festivals wasn't
monetary so what could it be instead and
then it hit me and it hit me so hard I
felt the need to write it down on my
whiteboard in my home office the
currency of the flow Arts had switched
from being actual currency to being
attention last year I had a conversation
on this topic with my friend Ember from
Boston and she described it with a
phrase that I had never heard before but
that I thought was an incredibly great
encapsulation of the concept she
referred to this as the validation
economy all right so what exactly is the
validation economy and why might it be a
bad thing well first up let's define
validation as I'm using it in this
context let's move this into the sun
shall we so I would Define validation in
this context as being a specific form of
external positive reinforcement and
specifically it functions as reassurance
for something that we are anxious in a
cure or fearful about specifically it's
something that makes us feel good about
ourselves when we are afraid that we are
inadequate now on the face of it there
is nothing wrong with receiving positive
reinforcement especially on things that
we might need reassurance about things
that we're insecure about or in moments
when we're facing our fears I think that
it becomes a problem though when a it is
used as a form of compensation and B
when it becomes institutionalized to the
point where it shifts the fundamental
relationship and social contract between
the audience and the performer and or
students and teacher part of what struck
me is odd about the shift in lineups for
Galas as well as teaching lineups is
that it effectively shifted things such
that the student's job became to
reassure the teacher that they'd done a
good job not that it was the teacher's
job to show up and teach a good lesson
likewise it was the audience's job to
show up and make the performer feel like
that they had put on a really good
performance rather than the performer
actually working to put on a good
performance and this basically creates
an ecosystem or social contract where
it's kind of a you scratch my back and
I'll scratch yours kind of situation
where it is assumed that you must always
give somebody positive feedback
regardless of how good a job that they
did in the expectation that they will
then give you positive feedback when
it's your turn to be on stage and
goodness do people get really really
really upset when this social contract
is broken so this is just a quick note
from drugs from the future after I
completed the video I realized it might
be a good idea to go back and have a
little section where I talk a little bit
about the fact that it does feel good to
be selected to teach or perform at a
festival you know feeling seen in that
way it it absolutely feels dynamite and
I have empathy for that I totally
understand why people rush to fill in
those slots and how good it feels to
feel seen and you know I get that it
sucks having somebody tell you that
something that may makes you feel good
is bad and for what it's worth I I don't
want you to feel as though I'm saying
you're a bad person for accepting
validation as payment but I do want you
to maybe take a little bit more time to
consider what the ramifications are of
that action that feels so good in the
moment and what the long term is and the
impact that that has on other people so
here are a few of the ways that I have
seen this manifest over the years one of
the ways that I've personally seen this
manifest with my own work is in
reactions to the POI top 10 list whether
it be people demanding that I expanded
out to a total of 20 slots instead of 10
which
it did not Escape my attention that a
lot of the people asking for it to
expand to 20 slots were the people that
would have been featured in it if there
were 20 slots
but there was also a certain level on
which people felt entitled to get time
on my channel and being featured on my
channel
and a lot of that felt like people
thinking that as they had watched my
content it was now my job to highlight
theirs drugs from the future once again
and I can't believe I forgot to bring
this up too but one of the other ways
that this manifests is in sponsorships
plenty of people are willing to call
themselves sponsored and basically give
endless amounts of free advertising to
companies that produce props for
literally no other reason than having
the label of sponsor makes them feel
really special and of course there's the
example that ember brought up when she
first shared the term validation economy
with me which is the example of
undercutting in professional
circumstances a lot of people just want
to feel seen so badly that they will
accept any amount of compensation or
none at all in order to participate in a
lot of events or music festivals and
this means that for the people that have
devoted their time and energy to doing
it on a professional level they're
getting undercuts and I know a lot of
people are going to tell me you know hey
I'd be going to the festival anyway it
doesn't really matter and yeah it does
actually matter friends it matters for
the person that you are taking food out
of their mouth
but I think that the negative
consequences of this aren't just
confined to these examples for one thing
when we create this ecosystem that is
specifically built around creating
social contracts in which positive
reinforcement is not just given but
assumed it basically creates a gigantic
neon sign welcoming narcissists and
abusers into this community because they
can be sure that they will receive the
endless amounts of admiration that they
require we've already seen in past years
how this has already become a big
problem and I don't think that the two
things are unrelated at all
this winds up making people in our
community less safe number two it makes
it more difficult to earn a living in
this community if validation is the
primary means by which people are
compensated by contributing to it guess
what all of us eventually have to pay
our rent or go shopping for groceries we
cannot eat other people's admiration and
when there's an enormous pool of people
that will accept validation as their
primary form of compensation it puts an
enormous amount of downward pressure on
actual wages on the amounts that
festivals are willing to pay for
teachers and performers and that makes
our lives harder and finally perhaps the
biggest problem with using validation is
compensation is that it spectacularly
fails at the entire point of using it in
this fashion to begin with the whole
reason we want to be generous with our
positive reinforcement and validation is
that so many of us are coming into the
flow Arts full of insecurity and fear
and we want to assuage that the problem
is that the long-term solution to that
isn't to receive a lot of external
validation for people to learn how to
validate themselves it's for people to
learn how to like themselves and when
they become dependent on external
validation it actually gets in the way
of being able to perform that function
for themselves paradoxically the real
goal here is personal growth and when we
externalize our need for that validation
it actually prevents the growth rather
than encourages it and I do want to take
one moment just to be abundantly clear I
am not saying that we should stop giving
people positive reinforcement I am not
saying that we should stop telling our
friends they're doing a good job we can
and should be generous with our praise
both to our friends as well as to the
people that Inspire us it is a good
thing to tell people good things about
themselves it just cannot be an assumed
or given part of how that economy works
okay so obvious questions what can we do
about it number one I think we need to
be more honest in our feedback and to
clarify a lot of people who say that
they favor honest feedback really just
favor not having to limit their cruelty
this is not a license to go be cruel to
people it is a license to admit to
yourself hey I didn't see anything that
inspired me in that Gala or I didn't
really learn anything in this
instructor's class it's okay to admit
that to ourselves and it's okay to say
hey I think that this experience could
have been better and I'm not afraid to
say it number two every single
instructor and every single performer
and for that matter every single staff
member at these events need to insist
that they're actually being fairly
compensated for the work that they're
providing for the event we should not be
looking at flow festivals as a place
where people go to get experience
teaching they should be doing that in
their own communities and taking what
they are learning from teaching others
to the flow festivals the flow festivals
should be places where we bring the best
of the best we should not be bringing in
people that have no experience in the
things that they're being hired out to
do there and number three I think that
it is not just important but apps
necessary that we call out events and
institutions that specifically exploit
the people that work for them in this
fashion look nobody likes getting called
out it brings up lots of feelings of
Shame it's really embarrassing but at
the same time if we're going to create
events and institutions that are
designed to be a benefit to the
community then we have to accept
feedback from that community of those
moments when we fall short
otherwise quite frankly the institutions
themselves are building up their own
sense of self around that validation
economy and that just becomes this weird
snake eating its own tail that I barely
know how to unpack right now so long
story short support your friends tell
them when they do a good job and also
tell them when they can improve on
things and do so with kindness because
ultimately the whole point of this is
not to make yourself feel better by
telling somebody else the ways that they
can improve it's to get that friend or
that institution to a place where
they're doing a better job at what
they're doing so that all of us have a
better time of it we all love to feel
seen it feels good to be selected to
teach or perform at a festival it feels
good to be on the lineup for a music
festival I'm not denying that
but at the same time we have to think
about the broader context of how that
works it cannot be just about how good
we feel in that moment but what do you
think am I being unfair in my assessment
here am I being too far reaching in how
I'm describing this problem
or is this also a problem that you've
noticed but didn't have a word to put to
it let me know down in the comments be
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to keep the conversation going as well
as to help my channel grow this video
would not be possible without the kind
support of all these nice people right
here these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you
watching right now are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards but even more
important you'll be supporting me in my
mission to create more videos like this
one and share POI spinning and flow Arts
with the whole wide world go check that
out please and thank you if you would
like to check out some other videos I've
done on Flow Arts culture both the
positives and the negatives I will go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might type
this that video here because it's very
popular amongst viewers of my channel so
maybe give that a look as well thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
to flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace